well hey everybody
this is sam with python basics and
uh glad to have everybody back today um
it is tuesday and we are just going to
pick back up where we left off so if
you're new here
thanks for joining us i'm sam from
python basics
and i'm doing a series uh with free code
camp
and we are starting from the beginning
as
we know nothing about python
well hey there hey everybody um so
a little bit of a recap and an
adjustment
to some things that we looked at last
tuesday so we had our first stream last
tuesday it was a two hour stream and
until
further notice we will do two hour
streams every tuesday
starting from the beginning and going
forward so
i have a youtube channel and
i started doing uh some recap beginner
streams
um two months ago and we are just
revisiting
excuse me we are just revisiting the
first
hundred videos so what we did last week
was we learned about uh conditions we
learned about
functions we learned about built-in
functions we learned out how to build
our own functions
so what we're going to look at first is
we're going to revisit
our positive negative clean that up a
little bit make that
even more pythonic and then we're going
to learn how to wrap that in a function
so let's just go ahead and jump into it
and then we're going to look at some
string formatting how to really clean up
our print
and to delve into it so let's get
at it so we were right
here last time and
so we were testing for a number if it
was
positive or negative well there's a
there's a there's a trick to that it's
actually three conditions
it's either zero or
then it's either positive or negative
and the way that we handled that is we
took
an if an elif and an else i want to show
you
another way and the way that i like to
do things is i build i build on it
then maybe show the best practice so we
take a step back and then we go forward
and forward and forward
to really get the best way to do it
but i like to then really have
it really cleaned up so it's either
positive or negative one side or zero
so let's clean this up
else so it's either right in the middle
zero
or then it's one of the other two so we
can go
if number
greater than zero print
let's make a capital positive
all right then we have an else
then we just have if
neg negative
all right now you might say what's the
difference
well we're going to build upon this but
this is
this is best practice because you then
clean
this up and if you have any condition
especially when we start doing maybe
bisectional
search or um binary binary
like binary tree it just helps you
understand that you come down and you
split and you split and you split and
you split
so unless you have three true options
fine you have your if your lf and your
else but it's r
it's really not you have two choices
then you split off and then you have two
more so now we have this this is great
but what happens if we have
we need this in a function so i'm going
to show you this because we want to use
yes right now it's it's usable it's
repeatable
but it is in a script let's just make
this
a function so let's look in this so you
can indent an entire region
so you come up here boom so then i'm
going to take this
and i'm going to wrap this in a function
i don't know why i keep hitting e again
i apologize everybody
um let's see what was i thinking so
then pause
neg and then i take x so we need to
clean this up
just a touch and i can't remember what
numbers did we use we add them
we add them up here let's
cut this and bring this down here so i
was thinking about this as i was setting
up this morning
i did not even put this code on my
github but at the end of today i i have
other code on there
uh all the code that i have in all my
videos but i'm gonna have another
section
that just has the code and the examples
from free code camp so i just want to
let you guys
know that uh today going forward after
we get done today
this will be back up uh
all this will be on and we'll just add
to it as the weeks go by
so okay so here we are so now we can
call this
oops what cardinal sin did i forget
i forgot my colon so there we are so now
i have
my function
in memory and i pass it a number
and then i get oops so i already have
this going through
my function up here but
let's say let's say that i wanted to
do this and let's bring this back one
the indent so now now i have this nice
clean function
so now i want to go through my list
got a little bit ahead of myself sorry
guys so
for number in numbers
then i'm going to now i have this
already printing so i don't need a print
statement
i'm just going to call my function
pause neg then i'm going to pass
it let's go half measures print number
so to remind you
i have
here's my list my iterable we're going
to do a lot with lists today we're going
to do
we're going to look at how to increment
a variable increment decrement
while loop and some things with lists
and a little bit more and we're really
going to look at list comprehension what
that is so if you're just jumping in
those are some of the things that we're
going to be uh attacking
and if you are just getting here i saw
quite a few more people
jump in i'm sam with python basics
thanks for joining us today we are
building uh upon
the basics of python from the beginning
so i get all these numbers printed out
so now let's just comment that i know
how to go through my list
now i want to call the function on each
iter in my iterable so this is my
container this is my iterable
i'm iterating through it here's my
temporary intermediary variable
so numbers is this list
i'm going to iterate through it until
this is exhausted until each item is
exhausted and then we're going to look
at a different type of loop so then i
just
call my function
and i put number boom
and then i get positive negative
positive negative
0 positive negative positive boom
that is one of the cleanest ways to do
this
so we don't have to go down here and
call
a call our function and pass it a
variable
this is nice best clean practices
so here we go all right
so next so now i want to look back
at let's do this comment this
out now i want to look back
at our loop that we have right here
that we used let's copy this bring this
down here
so what we did here is
we we went through and we made this
we got five row we got five columns
five rows and the way that python goes
is it goes row
by row by row by row you see whatever
so you see where i'm going with this but
one of the best practices that i really
like to show people
and really get them to think about is i
like to build
a number triangle so let's see
if i have this
ready to
run shoot because i want to show you i
don't want to show you the code yet
uh triangle where is it
okay there we go i hoped it would it
would open over here
so let me show you this it's gonna run
aha so this is what i want to show you
and i want you to think about this how
because this is a great exercise for
beginners
of how to go through and get
10 1 two ten rows
and have it increase as we go
so same principle over here but we have
to have
a lot more control over how things flow
says have anybody have any guesses
of how we might do this
all right let me click over to the
comments
all right so same nested loop
setup let's get rid of this right here
all right so the way that we're going to
do this
so we're going to get our base going so
we need we need 10
we need 10 rows so
for row in range
so i need 10
and why did that fail all right print
row
okay i got 10 but it's wrong
so i need 1 through 10
not 0 through nine so first problem we
have to solve
is we need to go one through eleven
because
to remind everybody inclusive exclusive
all right so first problem solved we
have
when we go row by row so now what i need
to do is i need to figure out how in the
world
am i going to get my columns
all right so this is where these
variables become very very very
important
so what is so awesome and i love
teaching
new people and especially young people
how in the world to handle
um repeatability and
think about the set of instructions of
how can i draw it
how can i think about it because i love
the example
it was actually something that i learned
giving the example i think it was
monsters and flowers
uh i was working with um
some kids so you step in you go straight
you turn you go down four turn all the
way around go back up four
and then you're literally back in the
same position so then you repeat that so
you figured
you want to figure out the set of
instructions that then you can do an
error that said i was disconnected
all right am i back everybody
am i back okay because i just got a
disconnection okay sorry about that i
don't know how long i was down i
apologize
my internet has been acting up of course
i did the famous
okay we are back okay thanks bo sorry
about that
all right okay so we need to get going
on our all right that looks a lot better
okay so we're gonna
we got our column and then we're gonna
look
so we know have have the numbers so now
we need to move across
so column in range
now how can we make this repeatable
so we know that the first time through
row is one so
the first time through i just need one
number then the second time through
i need two numbers the third time
through
i need three numbers so what do we have
that is already counting for us
by a certain set of numbers
first time through one number second
time through two numbers
third time through three numbers so this
way is the
one of the easiest ways so we're just
going to just going to steal
range excuse me row we already have row
doing all this incrementation for us we
don't have to
we don't have to reinvent the wheel
we're going to borrow row
all right now this isn't quite right
so print now what did we learn last time
we're going to print column
then we're going to suppress the
and then what we'll find out here is
that this is a little wrong
okay now uh oh
let's see where am i
let's see
okay so we're getting we're getting
close
and actually i forgot this
is a little different there we go
so that's going to the end but what do i
need
right here so i'm starting at zero but i
don't my
my original example is i didn't want i
didn't want zero i wanted to start at
one
but where's row starting it goes
here so i need to change this just a
touch
my start stop
now i want to show you let's get rid of
this
all right all right so i just gave a
return
and i emptied this right here
and i got my last number disappeared
so let me show you what this is so the
last time row
and this was one of the cool things that
i remember so these variables are
sitting there
so i run dur and i have my column and my
row variables
so my row variable i can always see what
the last call through a for loop is
i remember the first time i saw that it
like freaked me out and i was like
well it started to really wrap my head
around what was going on so the last
variable call for column
last variable assignment for column
is 9 and the last variable assignment
for row is 10. so let's
be the most correct and assign
one to row because row is
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
and i want 10 to come out
so i need to add 1 to beco make
10 be increme
inclusive and included now this is where
it gets
very challenging that what happens
if i go up to let's say 14.
oh yuck we can see
that this begins to taper off
and that's that's not pretty
that's not pretty at all so we are going
to learn
about a new tool
called how to uh string formatting so
we're going to actually
use a placeholder and we'll look at it
in just a second
and then as we're going to assign how
much space
do i want for
that i want to allocate for that
placeholder
so bingo row plus one all right
sorry i was clicking over between
okay all right so
we need to change this right here
we're gonna go boom
curly brackets dot
format
just like that
and then i close it
now this doesn't do anything oops oop my
bad
let's see where i am
and there
sorry okay so i have my placeholder
but i'm not really doing anything quite
yet so right now
this is how this is how you use a
placeholder and we're going to look at
this
with an example of uh
in a in a sentence here in a little bit
we're going to then look at our
hello function and build on that
so what i'm doing right here is i'm
telling python
that i have a placeholder and i want
this to be
the size of three
and then this is the variable that i
want to go
into this placeholder so let's
save and run this boom
just like this and of course then you
can change it to two
of course it'll be a little
little crowded here at the end so three
is
best for right now so you have a buffer
so you can read this so this
is one perfect example of how you use a
very clean
placeholder using string format so you
put
this string that you want inside inside
your quotations and i'll show you
we'll do the hello function again and
we'll and we'll neaten this
up dot format passing in
this so there we go awesome
let's see any uh good question
okay so now now let's look
at how in the world
could we utilize this who am i doing
are we doing uh no we'll do
input in a second yep that's what we're
going to do
alrighty so comment that out
so we had our function right
up here about taking in
hello we're saying
and hello this out there we go
boom all right good we're still green
so this got it done but
boy that's ugly
because then you know sam hello sam but
then what happens if i say i wanted this
to be a little bit more complex
hello sam
i gotta give it a space nice to
meet you
i remember when i learned this i thought
this was so cool
but man that's ugly so
let's copy this
put it down here comment that out please
now let's use
i got too many spaces
if you're just joining us i'm sam with
python basics
and we are doing live streams
we can throw in name and then i got my
print
and i do this just to check boom
and then i do sam we are doing live
streams for
basic beginners the beginning of python
because i know it is summer time
and everybody is getting ready for
school especially being at home
these times and fall is coming up and
school will be starting up school year
and we are going to be doing a
intro and introduction to python going
from the beginning
and going two hours every tuesday so
thanks for joining us today
so this is the
very nice clean string format of how you
get your placeholder
and then later we can even get fancy
when you have multiple
placeholders you can actually assign the
order of variables you want so
instead of having to reorganize your
list you can go oh well that one's
supposed to be there so you just go and
you change the
the location so there we go
all right
you can do that with an f string i was
going to build on that and build to it
sometimes the f string can be a little
overwhelming
so i like to show this first and i'll
make sure i have some f string notes
uh next week but yes you prefer f string
awesome some people get it what i've
found some people get
f string some people need to see this
first so
i um i like to show this first and then
show f string
but yes par f string
is the preferred because then you don't
even have to do anything but
i want people to kind of know where this
came from
and for it's i guess i also like to
uh it's like learn it's like learning
your multiplication tables
learn those first then you learn how to
use a calculator but awesome
f string is cleaner and even shorter
absolutely
that's true so you have options or so if
you're going along
uh and you see and you see this
you're like what it what is this because
you're gonna run across code and you're
gonna get to the point where you're just
reading
reading documentation and especially if
it's older code
um and it's it has this and you're like
what is this
i just think it is a
that's cool well i appreciate that guys
um i want you to know where it comes
from but no
in the in the iteration and there's
actually even an older placeholder where
you would have
you would do the modulo sign and an s
and f so for string um
uh float or digit and that was
that was annoying but i i like to show
this now because it's clean
and i've found that for newer people
excuse me
it's easier to wrap our head around and
then we can go from there
well i appreciate that that you are guys
there is a a lot there
it's over almost three and a half years
worth of uh
videos out there um
and over 740 i think
so all right we need to get going sorry
sorry for distracting
and getting off topic but i i could talk
about this for hours
as i'm sure you guys have already have
already noticed
okay let me see where we are with our
notes all right we're to the point now
that
now we need to look at how to handle
assignment reassignment
increment increment and decrement all
right we're to that point
because we're going to start learning
more with um
with the input so like i said before
python does everything on the right side
right side and then links or assigns it
to the variable
this took me forever to get i was like
this can't work it's
your you have itself you have itself you
have itself
shoot i'm getting ahead of myself all
right
so we assigned 0 to i we did it by using
the equal sign
linking that information in memory
python goes
ooh i know this i'm going to go to
memory i'm going to see and i'm going to
spit out
0. now i go here
and you see this and i call i and it's
one how in the world is this one it was
just
zero and now you have this thing on here
and you're telling me that this does not
throw up
nope doesn't throw up because again
python goes
into memory it says aha i know what
you're talking about
this you assign 0 to this so now
python doesn't see i it sees zero and
you want to add one to zero
then you assigned it so now okay you
seem to know what you're talking about
you called a variable that i've heard of
and now it is one is currently assigned
to that variable
the i'm gonna put it out on the screen
and so
now then what happened
is oops i apologize guys
so then python the
the core core developers go let's let's
uh
let's juice this up a little bit
because they were probably i like it
because i'm lazy so i don't want to type
all those characters i did not want to
type
i over and over and over again so now
i'm going to
increment by 1.
so now when i so last time i was
1 and now i
is two i'm incrementing
by one and this works for every
math operator in python
all right jan quick
what is i now if i press i
what will come out on the screen i don't
know what the lag
is i don't know i don't want to bore you
guys too much but it is now back to
one bingo
because it it decremented
now decrement and then this also works
for multiplication and division
it works for all all math operators
awesome
so yep you guys are correct
i really do love this interaction
because it makes it a lot
easier maybe at some point we could
figure out how to all be
uh or a few of us be on a uh
voice call because that would be very
cool for the interaction
all right so now now what we're going to
do
is we're going to do some math we're
going to work with our input
we're going to use our input do some
math
but there's going to be a problem and
we're gonna have to learn
how to handle this so
we have let's see increment
ah we need to touch on
well we can we can do this one of two
ways
let's let's look at because we're going
to look at
counting down so we're going to use a
while loop and then we need to take in
input so we're talking about numbers
right now let's go ahead and take this
in so i have my number
and we know how to
take an input from the user enter
a number and we give it a little space
so it looks nice and pretty enter a
number i'm going to
give it five now let me click back over
to
our chat window
if you press i twice would it
if i press i twice
okay let's go over that for a second so
if i
if i then call i again no
now what we're gonna look at
well hey there hey guys um i see a
couple more
folks have joined us we are we are
working with
incrementing and decrementing right now
but if i'm just calling the variable now
if i called this
okay if i called this
over and over and over again which we're
going to look at in a while loop
so let's okay let's see how many times
we do this
so i just it was one and i just ran it
two more times what would it be
jan i know you were typing uh
so if i just ran if i decremented
i twice by one what would i be right now
negative one negative 1 and we're going
to look at this in in a while loop
so let's deal with this and then we'll
kind of wrap our head around this a
little bit more
so now bingo negative 1. all right
so we just called
we just took this in
and number five
okay that is a five but i want you to
look
right here
what do we know about that any thoughts
but if we're not sure we have this handy
dandy
function built in for us that handles
everything it's a string what is a
string
it's not an integer or a float so can i
do any math operation
can i do any math operation on a string
cleanly technically we can get around it
but i don't want to talk about that
function
can i do can i do
this bingo
i cannot do that you have to convert it
bingo jan
how how can i do that
so i'm going to come back over here so i
have number
so input
enter number
all right fantastic
all right so for anybody who is
super new we can do this the long way
we're going to show long way
then i can now it didn't
print type because when you wrap
a string in a print it prints out pretty
five and um there we go
string and uh
there we go let's see
so we have we have this
in the background hey um i want to ask
you guys because i do not want to drive
you guys nuts can you hear an alarm in
the background
just somebody tell me real fast if you
can hear it's not going to bother me but
i do not want it to drive you guys nuts
can you hear a beeping in the background
anybody if you can't great i can ignore
it
okay good awesome okay i do not i just
don't want you guys to be on this stream
wanting to
kill yourself ah okay great okay let's
keep going
one of my kids forgot to turn their
alarm off and they've already left for
the day
so i get to hear this for an hour and a
half hopefully somebody will come home
soon all right
so we have a problem we cannot do so
you cannot so python goes okay you have
a string
you can't concatenate see that that's my
first so then if i go one
so check this out
so i put a string first so python goes
okay now i'm gonna trust that you know
what you're talking about
so you're gonna try to concatenate one
because i have
a string and i'm using my addition
operator
and i'm trying to add one that says you
can't connect concatenate but then when
i give it an integer first
and then give it my variable it says you
cannot
unsupported operand so i can't it has to
be
it has to be an int so i can take this
the long way so i can go number
int hint number
that's that's long that's longhand enter
number
int or i remember the very cool first
time i saw this i was like this is so
cool
so we did this with our range in our
list
i can literally just wrap perfect i can
wrap an
int function around my input function
and this works this is
completely legal and it's pythonic
this is best practice and then
i kick this out so now now what we're
going to look at is we're going to take
in a number
and we're going to count down we're
going to count down
from that number whatever number we pass
in and we're going to count down like a
countdown sequence and then we're going
to print blast off
this was uh one of the very first early
exercises and i love
i love doing it because you have to be
paying attention
to the order of operation and anything
that you want to have happen
in your certain order so let's look at
the while loop
so what is the while loop key
how do we get to our interactive help
help keywords
boom and let's give us some more space
so we can clean this
while so let's look at weil all right
while statement is used for repeated
execution as long as an expression is
true
super important we'll only operate if
it's true
just like our if and our
elif the statement after has to be true
in the header for the body to be
executed
so let's look at this so we are on line
378 everybody look right there everybody
sees that line
three seven eight so while
true print
hi all right we're on 378 right
now we're on 380 ready okay come up here
stop shell restart shell i'm on 740.
so this just ran through a ton
of stuff bam there it is
and you're like okay so what does so
influence can be achieved by
yes an infinite loop with while true
and what i want you to think about is i
remember
when i was really getting started and i
got i got asked by
a young man in in class that i was
teaching
and he said why not a for why
why a while loop instead of a for loop
so you can just know how many times
to to do it well then i was sitting
there thinking
and again i was still at the beginning
and i said okay well
minutes before i learned anything about
windows or running up high window or
a tkinter window i said i want you to
think about it
your um your window your chrome
is sitting there open it is running and
the first thing it's doing is it's
running a while true loop
until you hit that x and then it closes
everything down
that is a perfect example of while so
i'd like to do this countdown
method with blast off and then we go
from there
so we have let's comment this out and we
will go
while while
count we'll change this to count so be
really on point
count while count is greater than zero
we're going to then print count
now wait a minute let's think about this
so if i pass a five right now
it's just going to print count over and
over and over again
but i want i want to do something right
so we're going to then take
count then we're going to decrement it
every time through
by one now what we need to decide
is we're gonna we're gonna make some
mistakes here and then we're gonna fix
this up
so i'm going to go through here enter a
number
we're just gonna go 5. so four three
two one zero hmm
i didn't print out five but i've entered
five
so what should i do
um where
where should i put where should i put my
decremented
uh statement
it's not working i didn't get five to
print out on the front end
so we're gonna move it down here
so now i'm gonna get
perfect after my print statement
now what happens if we say ready
then we start the count so i'm taking in
my input
i want to print out ready
i don't know where i got oh i got ahead
of myself ready
then i start my then i start counting at
five four three two one
but now i don't have
zero hmm
but i want zero so
[Music]
how can i do that so now we got a set of
i guess it depends on the use of what
you want to get out of the number
um
[Music]
all right so we need to think about this
so if i want to
include in zero so we need to think
about so all right we got
i got my ready and i solved my problem
of
aha i like that
zero greater than or equal to zero
fantastic
five so now i have ready five four
three two one zero okay then it
exterminates
what happens if i wanted something like
blast off to happen where would i
where would i put that so if i put it
here
it would happen every single time right
so i go print blast
off and i get a bunch of it's super cool
and super exciting so i
i want exclamation points so i get
five and i get oh
outside the while loop exactly so i come
here
and i hit my backspace one time so
python
takes care of that for you i move it out
of my body
so i have my header i have my body
and then i move it outside the body so
it will only happen
one time perfect so then i get my five
five ready five four three two one zero
blast off boom i'm without
the yup yup yup exactly you guys
you guys are on it today very very good
now now i want to look at
lists so do i still have a list in
memory
and i comment everything out okay let's
do while i'm doing this everybody in
comments comment uh
where you're from uh
because i am very curious actually
getting some stuff around because most
of and if you're just joining us today
i'm sam
uh with python basics uh partnering with
bo and free free code camp
and um we are doing two hour streams
every tuesday um with a
granted it's the world's fastest
countdown
that is true that is very true um
uh we are doing two hour streams and
uh this is this is basic beginner stuff
so if you are
china also very cool
because what i what blows me away is uh
the audience on my youtube page
is uh from all around the world
uh i it is extremely humbling
so we got china uh india
that is very cool yes actually a
majority
the largest the largest percentage of my
audience
is uh is from india uh slovakia
very cool that is so cool all right
so let's we have let's put this in
memory
so we have a list a list is the very
basic
uh is a very basic container in python
so we got and i call it numbers okay and
if you forget
you call your call your dir with no
with no information and you get numbers
so there we go
oh awesome um
okay now what do how can we find out
things about
a variable what are we the things
associated
and what are those things called
so any anybody
anybody got any thoughts
all right so we got numbers
and we run dur on numbers
let's see so we're not gonna
oh i apologize i was looking for the
methods
how do we so the the functionality of
what we can do
with a list and i was looking for
methods um
and i just want you guys to start
thinking about that
so we're gonna look at append
and then we're gonna look at list uh
list comprehension
so right now what we're gonna look at is
i want to take
a um i want to take a
list and we want to put it
if it is in a positive
list ooh that was a no no
or a negative list so we're going to
have an empty list
and a we're going to have an empty
positive list
and an empty negative list
let's see oops
all right and sorry
and so now what in the world so we know
how to iterate through
number in numbers
and we go through and we're just gonna
print out
number
boom okay but now we have
i was talking about append so let's look
at what a pen does
and how do we do that we do help on
[Music]
numbers dot append
what in the world does this do append
object
to the end of the list so if i have
my pause over here which is an empty
list
and then i go pause dot append
let's see pause dot append
and i give it four now pause
it has four and
and negative 3
then negative has negative 3.
so what could i do here
take everything that we know and then i
can go
and go if number
greater than zero
if if num and numbers if num greater
than zero
boom that is perfect so then i go
pause dot append
and then i give it number so then if
that's that
what should else be what should else be
if i can actually spell else today
all right so then negative
dot append number
right so i run this i call pause
if i can spell pause then i call neg
so bam so now i have a way
to do this okay when you're first
learning
this is fine this is perfect and
in a week or two when we start getting
into
uh some upper level
modules we're actually i'm going to
actually then show you
how list comprehension is faster so
let's go ahead
and jump into
list comprehension so what is list
comprehension
list comprehension is a way all the
instructions are
actually inside the list let me just
show you
so we're just going to do a real clean
and easy one
um we'll trump numbers here and we'll go
so the way that i like to explain this
is we got
4 i in range
10 10.
so start start with your header
your your loop your for loop header
now when you get more comfortable with
this you'll get it let me click over
here
see if anybody anybody ever seen list
comprehension
before you probably have because you
guys seem
uh pretty knowledgeable already
okay all right let's let's jump at it
and then we just put i so that's the way
it works
the variable goes to the front so it's
basically
how do i want to do this and what are my
okay and that's fine that's absolutely
fine that's what we're all here for
uh you're here to ask questions and
learn and
make me better and my job is to
uh do this that i absolutely love so
all right but you do this wrapped inside
your
your list brackets so now i run this
and i call numbers i call it number or
numbers numbers
boom so i already have so this is
that this is everything built built on
one
and you might say well why didn't we
just wrap list around our range
well because we are that that's the
basic
list that i awesome well then good i'm
so excited that i get to be the one
to show you guys this now
now the way that this works is now we
add
our conditions so we're going to change
this to positive
pause equals
now we go if we have no colons
if i
uh yeah we'll do this we'll keep it this
way
if i
greater than zero
all right
sorry guys sometimes it hangs up
and now i need to change that's what i
was looking at my notes going
that doesn't make any sense well it
doesn't if you don't read the notes
right
sorry guys so all right so to revisit
list comprehension and lambda functions
are my
awesome because we're actually going to
be doing a lot
with list comprehension and lambda i
don't know if we'll get
all the way through the lambda because
what we're about to do very soon and
we're going to start
on is one of the questions that i ran
across a couple of years ago
uh let's say it's an inter it's probably
not an interview question
anymore because it is so widely known
but here's the premise i'm going to give
you
you have 25 horses and you have to find
the fastest horse oh
and you don't have a stopwatch oh
and you can only race five horses at a
time
how many races what is the shortest
number of races
that you can do to win to get the answer
that's that's the question that we're
going to be solving well actually
proving so what the premise is
is you have your 25 horses let's just
jump into it
and and we're going to build upon this
so what the premise
of this is is let me find
the the list
sorry i did not think we'd get there
already so i'm super excited because you
guys are really really smart
and uh it is so super easy so all right
it is super super cool so here we go
so you have a list and so i was thinking
about this and i go this is a perfect
tutoring problem a perfect video
so if you want to get ahead and we don't
get to it
you can go and watch it uh of course
these are
everything that we're doing here is on
my uh youtube channel
but it does not have these subtle
nuances and especially during live chats
we always get into more i will just tell
you that right now
uh i have the main topics but then we
always wiggle off
into uh something else that's why
i absolutely love these live streams is
because you get into deeper deeper it's
kind of like audio books where you
are talking about something and then you
remember something else and then you go
off onto a tangent so great if you read
the book
awesome you get the red the red the
audio you always get a little bit more
so that's why i love these
live streams so okay all right so the
premise of this
is that the long the long term that
we're going to be working on
and we're going to we're going to use
all our skills to do this and we
especially need
a uh we're going to we're going to look
at lambda we're gonna do this two ways
we're gonna use this
with a sorted and a key function and
then we can also use lambda
but yes lambda you're exactly right
lambda
and list comprehension extremely similar
they look they look extremely the same
and i get it
when i was first looking at this it just
doesn't make any sense
but we'll go through it enough times and
you'll get it
excuse me all right but the premise of
the 25
uh horses and you can do it
in is it is it six races
six or seven we'll prove it and we'll go
through so you break the horses up
into into
groups of five so you run five races
you have those horses be in there and
they're uh
in the order that they won the race
super simple
you don't have to you don't have to do
anything else
then you have the horses
that won those races
race awesome it's seven it's seven
so you have then those horses run their
race
so then now you have
these in order of the of the of the
speed
that they have that they've won
then you have the the first horse
of each race race so then now you have
anybody got any guesses a list
of lists in order in which
they go now
i think i misspoke you will always know
which horse is the fastest because it
will always end up here and i designed
this
puzzle and to use numbers because
it's 1 through 25 so they're going to
order themselves
in 1 through 25 right so but the kicker
is
is this will not necessarily always be
the second fastest source what happens
if you had the second
fastest horse just randomly happen to be
here so the way that you then have to
slice this
and then run one more race
is we have to come here and get that
horde it's this diagonal right here
it's this horse this horse these two
horses
and these three horses always
that you will get the top three horses
and i even i think i expanded it to
the top five that's i think it's
actually these three
are the top three always but the top
five
will always reside here i believe or you
get the top three i can't remember
exactly
but we're going to slice this through
we're going to create a list of lists
then we're going to have these get
ordered
then have the lists be ordered by the
last place
and then we need to slice this right
here
to get the next one so let's just go
into it we have
one hour left i think we can get through
all of this
so we have a lot of work to do here so
how in the world
do we need to start any guesses
so first we need to get a list full of
lists
and have have it
chopped up so we're gonna need to learn
about
a couple of a couple of things here
so we need to bring in
we need to look at
well i appreciate that uh
so we looked at der
uh on our on our numbers
because then we need to bring in a
function so we need to
i think i'll go from because you're
you're lost
all right we're gonna go step by step by
step
so first step was we need to build a
list of lists
so this is what's so powerful about
lists
is it can contain anything it can even
contain
an item that's itself so let's just go
ahead and look at this
and we're gonna do this with list
comprehension at first
so um
num num nums
that's silly i'm sorry list
numbers
okay all right so here we go
we're going to do this with this
comprehension first
actually to make this real clean let's
do this with with a loop
all right list
numbers
we're going to make a bracket empty list
then for i in
range three
then list
numbers dot append
then i'm gonna insert a list of
range one through six
close this out so what am i doing
i have a range one through six so it
doesn't go to six it goes to five
so then i have a list of one through
five
inserted inside a list
three times okay and what'd i do
and do to do to do one two
okay why'd that fail everybody look at
that let's do that again
i ran this whenever you get this
indention
and the syntax thing it's the last
little bit of code that you wrote
so i did that ah it gray to everybody
see that gray out
gray out gray out boom so now it runs
and then i go list numbers
ooh okay this looks different
i have
bingo missing parentheses so now i have
a list because i see my brackets
but then i have here so if i
clean this up for i
in list
numbers print print
i aha
so i have a list of lists i have
three lists inside of a list
okay so now
so i want now random
i want randomly generated numbers
inside my five lists
so i could do this a couple of ways
and since list comprehension can be a
little challenging we're gonna do this
both ways all right
let's let's just jump into it
so we need to learn about a uh have we
imported
have we imported anything yet i can't
remember did we
we imported mac we did import math did
we import anything else did we look at
random
jan are you still here did we look at
random last week i can't remember
awesome okay random we haven't okay
awesome so when you're wanting
especially when we're doing this
i do not and you should not
want to type when when after we do this
so when i've been sitting here typing
this
you're not going to do that anymore and
we are not going to do
don't remember import okay import
import is a way to bring in another uh
file and namely uh and i like to
differentiate a module is
a module that is already built in that
is already in python
it's a python file that is already
brought in
and when you download python a library
i like to say library because that means
that is a third party
that you need to go out download it
bring it put it on your computer
and then you still import it the same
way
so here we go i didn't do anything
actually let's look at
i skipped this i don't like when i skip
stuff anymore
keywords let's look at
import it's a lot
important statement basic import
statement
find module loading initialize if
necessary
it's already brought in so
what is let's get out of here do i have
yep how do i know random still there
because i ran an empty
empty dirt command so now
what what does random do
random so here whoa
very cool stuff
randent we're not going to run help
on all of random we're now going to run
help
on random dot
brand int
okay return we know what return means
let me see
am i still in feel myself getting lazy
and not sitting up straight
all right return we know what return
means
means it creates stuff creates random
rand
int creates random integer in range now
here's
something that is counter to everything
we have talked about so far
so this is why reading the documentation
is so very important
all right rand int works
including both end points so this is
inclusive so if i go
for i in
range 10
close out print now
it's going to go through 10 times so
we're not going to do anything with i
we're just going to
print random dot rand int
uh one through five
and then close that out boom run this so
ten times random
was looked at rand ant was looked at
and one through five was randomly choice
chosen now we'll deal with this very
soon
how python randomly chooses things
because uh there is no random
functionality in computer science
or pseudorandom now we can get
more into depth but that's your little
nugget for
there is humans are the only people able
to choose random and then there's
actually proof that
we don't actually pick random numbers
either but
for all intensive purposes these are
randomly chosen numbers
they're mathematically chosen
pseudorandom
so now that
is how you pick numbers of
a certain choice so but
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a list
and we need to randomly mix it up
shuffle what does shuffle do
help random dot
shuffle okay
let's see make sure i haven't looked at
this stream in a while all right we're
still good
okay all righty
everybody good so far we still
we still good with this all right
cool so what this does is it takes
a list x
now this is super important
in place this is this is
really good documentation return so it
it states both both both conditions
it is in place and to be
even more clear it says return
none all right so it returns
none it is in place that means
if you are not creating a new variable
you're going to lose the original data
let's look at it
so now i have
let's see so if i come over here
and i'm going to let's look numbers
and you always don't forget we need to
import
import random
okay let's see
all right sorry i thought my phone was
about to ring
all right we let's put this in less
comprehension we'll do it one more time
for i
nope for i in
range 10.
so we just did this over here now we're
going to slap this
inside a list comprehension and it's
literally just this
random.randint
one through five and i close this out
give me a little space run this
numbers so now that number
so now i have excuse me
so now i have a list of how many was it
i have a list of 10 so it doesn't assign
like shuffled list no
if if if i did that
that works so very good question
if uh no no i'm sorry no
it returns none so that that that will
not work so you would need to
um you would then need to
uh oh i can't see it in my head right
now
uh you would then need to make a uh
copy because it return it returns none
it just it just uh changes it
all right and then we can talk about
copy deep copy
because copy has some odd uh
functionality
uh so all right and then you have deep
copy because it's just uh and then i
actually that's very good because then
because then when you start to
have your like and is
uh and equal to so things will be equal
to but it is not the same variable
that's that's uh that's actually a
really good thing for
next week for us to talk about because
that gets pretty nerdy pretty quick and
that is
so up so up my alley okay
um so okay i digress so now we need to
get a list
of 1 through 25 right
and it just needs to be and then we need
to shuffle that
and because there there's multiple steps
to this so we need to get a list of 25
then we need to shuffle it then we need
to chop that up and
spread that out sprinkle that over our
25
other lists so let's just go ahead and
do it
so we don't need no
i'll leave that there so you guys can
see it yes don't ever
don't ever delete any side note don't
ever delete any of your code
save it i hate that i had
one or two computers crash before i
really got halfway decent so it was
but i would love to be able to go back
and see what that looked like but
save all of your code for a variety of
reasons because then if you created
something you didn't quite remember what
you did
just comment it out or save it or move
it put it off
especially if you have something working
definitely save that because when you'll
see when you the more the more you make
complex things
and you start going and tinking around
with it
especially only change one thing at a
time
that's we'll we'll delve into that uh
very soon all right
we need to get a list of 25 numbers
uh doom boom close bracket
i
for i in range
so i want 1 through 25 right
so i go 1 through 26
close that out
so now i have
um the numbers
that i made with numbers yeah okay so
step one i have my
i have my numbers but now i need to
shuffle it
excuse me
[Music]
um
i got my random so numbers
dot shuffle and how do we use it
just like this random shuffle
now this is also very important and i
just used it wrong
random this is why you pull up the
documentation
because shuffle if i'd had done that i
would have needed
to have numbers
for that to have worked shuffle needed
to have been a method
numbers and shuffle does not
is not a method reverse is there sword
is there
but shuffle is not and the way that it
works is
random shuffle then you pass it it's
iterable
bingo random.shuffle iterable numbers
so you're dropping it in to the blender
and then calling it that's why that's
why it returns none
all right it goes in place and now we
call this
boom boom boom so now numbers it's all
it's all in the blender so here we go
so now i have a
very shuffled
list now now we're going to go through
and grab one of these out
and place it in our list one
at a time so we're gonna go really slow
since uh
list comprehension can be very
challenging
we're going to come here and
so what we're going to do is so we can
run this over and over and over again
and
go step by step
uh shuffled
we're gonna use this list because if we
were to run that code
over and over and over again it
seems
and did i do that right bam okay
so if i were to rerun this code every
time our numbers would be changing and
uh that always messed me up took me a
little bit when i was learning
why is that why is this happening so now
we have our shuffled list so that is the
way you get a shuffled list
created not even having to think about
it at at all
anymore we got our completely random but
now we want a list of lists all right
so how can we do that we're going to do
this
uh really really slow
and i think we can get started on the
actual
problem what's the exact time for the
next week's
class uh it'd be 10 a.m
eastern so
uh the 21st 10 a.m i've been meaning to
get
the wrap my head around what time utc
time
um so
and you're my goodness so
it'd be it'd be mid-afternoon but i will
i will start
getting get in the habit of uh
okay oh well thank thank you
my my local time 10 10 a.m
eastern all right
okay so let's go awesome
okay um where are we
okay so we need to create a list
of five empty lists and we need to look
at this right here
we need to look at what pop does
pop is a very cool and interesting
method
so it actually goes to one of the items
in the list
removes it
oh let's just read okay so help
how do we find out how do we find out
what um
how some of these methods work numbers
dot
pop
and this is important so okay
remove and return
item at index
the default so we need to we need to go
we need to look at this what does this
mean
all right anybody got any clue
default last
so when we are looking at indexing
indexing works the same on strings and
on lists
that's why i really like teaching those
uh
almost last item bing bingo negative one
is the last item
so
numbers
yeah we call this shuffled okay so
here's an awesome okay i'm gonna be mean
i'll bring this over so we're gonna do
this twice and i'm gonna see how
much i'm getting across so we just
called numbers
right here this is numbers so if i call
negative one on numbers why isn't this
typing
i was halfway through the first
uh drink and now i've taken two sips out
of the second
so i've since the stream started i've
only had
technically about a half a drink so
about eight ounces
but i did keep opening them a lot but no
i've only had about a half a drink
but i do drink a lot i do um like my
kids make fun of me
okay so if i go negative one
oh my goodness okay numbers
so numbers is right here so if i go
negative 1
what comes out for numbers
here's here's numbers right here
what comes out for numbers
oh trust me i i i eat lots of uh
carbohydrates and uh fruits and
vegetables
all right
no i i love milk 18. bingo now
all right everybody look over
oh shoot i haven't made the list of
lists yet i forgot all right
so we need to make a list of five empty
lists
we'll just call this horses
then boom and we'll move this down
then boom boom
boom boom how could we do and then
we'll look at this in a minute or two
how could we do this with list
comprehension
one two three four
all right is that everything so now i
have
why is my keyboard acting up sorry guys
okay one two three and then i check
because my eyes are playing tricks on me
horses okay i got five empty lists
so hmm i need to go
through now you could make this even
more even more random
but then you could actually undo some
randomness but i will show you this
i will show you one more uh
instead of doing that let's just run dur
on random
this is very cool abcde
choices choice and choices
help random
dot choice okay
choose a random element from a non-empty
sequence
so i could literally not only i could go
in order
and have pop just grab this last item
until the list is exhausted
and just go here and as we come through
but what will happen
is this will go here this will go here
this will go here here
so we could technically accidentally
know and we'll know the order
so basically it would go
so our list and i guess we could check
it we could leave this this way where
that
so this column will be in this first
list this column will be in the second
list
this column will be in the third and so
on because as we go through
we're gonna go for every five we're
gonna fill up row one
two so it's like counting off people one
two three four five one two three four
five as you're going through the room
and you put
all the ones over here all the twos over
there so if you're paying attention
you could actually know who's in which
one and the
and the and the people in groups could
accidentally
figure out who's in what group so you
could
actually then use choice
to then go through and randomly choose
so i'll leave that up to you for you
guys to practice on your own and if
that's a challenge we can look at that
next week so all right so first we need
to go through
our shuffled list pop it out and look
each time through so we need to
we need to figure this out
we need to look at it
all right so first we got to wrap our
head around
how can we get to each list
for i in
horses print i
okay so we're going to use a for loop
to get to each of the lists
that's what we're gonna do
for race here here we go for race in
horses
print race all right
because each of these each of these uh
each of these brackets each of these
lists is a race
that's how i want you to think about it
now they're not they haven't raced yet
but we're gonna put them in their group
for their race that's how i want you to
think about this
okay so there that that's the race right
now so we don't need that
but we know how we're gonna touch each
each one
and we know that we're gonna use pop
help help list
pop pop
all right remove and return
so it's going to go and grab and return
it
so it's creating something so i can then
use this
uh so then i'm going to go
let's see where i am so each time
through so
but actually oh i'm gay i'm getting
ahead of myself
i was explaining that but we need to go
through this list 25 times
so this is actually let's see
we need to go through here 25 times and
grab
out and then place it in there so i
guess i haven't done this in a while
there we go all right
so for horse
and shuffled there we go
let's comment that out for a second
print course
here we are all right
so for each time through here's here's
our horse here's our horse
number and actually we already know the
speed that they that they are so we're
already going to know
we already know how fast they are we we
want to test
we are testing this scenario of
how fast are these horses so we've i've
seen this
we've seen it jump up a little bit so if
you're if you're just joining us today
what we're doing is we're actually
looking
at a puzzle a interview question
of how to find 25 horses
um and how to find the the fastest three
horses
with and you don't have any timing
material you don't have a stop watch
you don't have any way to time them so
what we're doing is we're gonna
we the answer is
the answer is uh and and also how
fast can you do it and the answer is
would i say seven
we do five races sort the r uh then you
race the
last the fastest of those horses and you
take the diagonal
and you slice that out and then you have
your and you sort that and you have your
fastest
so we have to take a list of 21 through
25
we're going to shuffle those randomly
then place
each of those numbers in a list
so let's just have at it so we got our
we have our races
we have this right here shoot
so then what we have to do is then we
have to go through
and place each each
horse in each
one right here so as we go through
so there we go all right
let me check my notes because i already
made one mistake with that
there's our 25
and we pop that out
okay
all right
[Music]
for
j
there we go for i in
and horses
because that's five so we're going to go
through then for
j in
range five because we're going to do
this five more times so actually
let's look at this like this
because i i was looking at my notes
closer
so if we think about it we got columns
and rows
i think i changed back to this because
it got too complicated
for everybody and then
horses there we go
because then we have to have the index
of each one zero one two three
four all right that was it that's why i
dropped
the other way i knew sorry guys oh god
got ahead of myself
i did not think we'd get to this but you
guys were asking about
lambda and this is a perfect landa and
especially list comprehension
so we can then then i'm going to show
you how to do this
all on one line and it will blow your
mind
so all right for j or this is the index
then we're going to append to
that list so i want you to think about
this we're going to go through this
five times then we're going to go
through
each of these five times that's what
we're doing so we got
25 so 5 by 5 then we're going to pop
out this now you could you could then
you could rent but you don't want to use
random choice because then it's going
through but you
you could but then you'd still have to
delete it
and then we'd have another issue we'll
deal with that next time
but all right uh we have our shuffled
so i want to remind you what shuffle
does
shuffled what uh pop does
shuffle dot pop
all right so let's come over here before
we run this so what does
what does pop do shuffle dot pop
help
shuffled dot
pop this is what i thought was
so so very super cool
so you actually get
this it returns removes the last item
bingo
or nested loop much easier okay inside
the horse loop if shuffled bingo
so is it still till four equals shuffled
pop
uh yes but then you have to append so
that's why we're using
this right here so we're going to append
this
in this list so we randomly go here put
that in there
then the next time through here
we're going to go because when we get
down here we're going to go
five times so this way five times
and then this way five times so we go
boom first time through
here and then we're gonna come down this
way
boom boom boom boom and i didn't do
horses
there we go so first time through here
is zero
so zero one two three four
and then because here did we put that in
we need to look at this
zero because they're empty lists right
now
two three four
sometimes this can be
i got so excited that we were getting to
this already all right so horses
horses not howarses all right
so if i do if i do
uh horses
index uh three
i should change this here
that was silly zero
they're in order so that's gonna uh
one and then three all right so let's
put this back in memory
delete that
put this back in memory all right
horses okay so each of this
horses index zero
is two horses
index three
is zero one two three
is one so each time through here
i go through i could i should have said
uh yeah i should have just said horses
because that'd be five um but i think
the last time i did this
it really confused uh a lot so that's
why i think i changed the notes
so let's just run this and go through so
then i call
horses
so boom then let's do for
i in for race in
horses
print race
okay there we go let's go through this
one more time
25 five times five twenty-five so we
wanna go through this
sorry one of my dogs wants to come
inside
they have to stay outside because they
are loud
so all right let's see if we can how far
we can get in the next uh
20 24 minutes all right
so we got now now we need to figure out
so we have we have our rate we have our
races
set we have not raced yet
does anybody have any guesses how we are
going to
race these horses to get them in order
any thoughts
all right and i'm not even halfway yet
so technically i've not even drank a
whole drink today
so i think i drank two last last stream
all right so we have got to learn about
how to sort
sort a list so there is
i think i saw somebody write some i see
duplicate numbers
do we
really
you sure
okay
oh inside the horse list
uh ooh yes we do
oh i did not remove these
thank you great catch because there
are six there so now let's run this
again
for race in
horses
print race there we go
awesome catch very very good
there we go so yes i left my uh
that example sitting up there very good
catch
that's why i love having um
interaction and uh these live streams so
now is anybody got any guesses
uh how to then run this race
and get these in order
okay very cool i will see you next week
so let's look
at uh horses
we're gonna run dir on
horses
okay all right oh
sort let's run help
on horses
uh apparently i need to pick another
not help on horses help on
horses dot sort
so how does this work let's move this
over just a little bit more
all right so sort sort a list in
ascending order return none
super important so now this
documentation left out
in place but same same rule
same everything ascending order
or in place returns none
so now i have a list of lists
so horses a list of lists so lend
on horses
five okay so if i want to go
through and race each race
i then have to
well first let's come over here and
call this so this doesn't keep changing
horses so now i'm going to
comment this out and
then i guess i can leave that
horses equals
grab these so now this sets in memory
and
let's see
get this one here
this one here this one here
this one here so i have my lists of
lists
so now i want to go through and i need
to see
and sort each list
so for race
in horses
race okay so how does this work
so i take my list and i just run
sort okay
and it goes in ascending order
and i could use a key but we're not
going to deal with that right now
oh did i still not get this scooted over
enough
okay okay it does say it down here i
thought this one did
sort the sort is in place all right
so returns none is in place
super important because we're just going
to then
run race dot sort
that's it all right
so i do this and then
and then i got my horses
then i go for race
in horses
print race should have done this over
here
okay so now now we're getting serious
here
so now we got these are in ascending
order
because we learned that sort
goes in ascending order and if we wanted
if we wanted to do it the other way if
we wanted
if we wanted it to be first the first
place
on the left and go go this way
let's copy
paste
now let's look at this optional argument
this is important
reverse equals false so it is
you have two ways to think about this
default argument
optional argument all right this is how
i want you to think about this
this is optional because it's already
assigned and we actually have a cool
puzzle we'll do
uh later with a randomly generating
a password handles all this very very
cool
multiple options all right so the way
that this i don't i don't have to assign
reverse because it already is assigned
so it's defaulted
uh two
i could have sworn it said default in
here so you have the reverse flag that's
another way
so it's sitting here but so if i want
this and i want the first place at the
beginning of the list and work through
i do this equals
so this is what it calls reverse is true
it calls reverse from top back
let's run this because actually you know
what
see that is that right yes
so here we go so now what we need to do
is we need to let's see if we can get
this done in 16 minutes
so now we need to have the last place
excuse me
the the first the first place horses
race
so then we can sort these in order
right so let's get after that so now
what we need to do
is we're going to we're going to build a
function
and then then maybe we'll look at lambda
oh uh who wanted to look at who was
having a hard time with lambda
are they still here are they gone
i can't remember i know a couple people
just left
oh sorry i thought somebody pulled up
okay
all right everybody you're ready let's
see am i still sitting
all right so now what we need to do
is we're going to create a function
called last
i think somebody just wrote something
okay
we're going to do it with a with a
defined function
and then what we'll do is then we'll do
it with lambda
because i think if i do it this way it
might cement lambda for you
all right
but if you are just joining us today
right now
i'm sam with python basics and we are
working
on the beginning the basics of python
and what we're doing right now is we're
working on a puzzle
of how to find the fastest three horses
in a 25 group of horses without a
stopwatch
or any timing material so return
x negative one
negative one so this took me
a minute to wrap my head around but what
we're doing
is we're gonna we're gonna use another
function that
is perfect for this because
um you also have sorry
you can do this with sort but i want to
introduce you to sorted
help it's another awesome we got sorted
okay so it is a built-in function
that takes an iterable return a new list
of in ascending order so the same thing
right here and it takes a key
so reverse is defaulted
to false and key is defaulted to none
so we're going to get rid of this
because right now
this sort that's why i remember we don't
do this
sorry because if you sort these lists
it will look at the first item that's
why i had it in
the other order now i remember so that's
why we have to use list
so let's bring this in and so we have
this
because the default is is python will
look at the first
like if you sort a list of if you give
it a list of letters
if you give sorted a list of letters it
will sort
by the first letter and if you give it a
list of lists
it'll sort by the first number but we
want to make this challenging and we
want to learn
and you typically read left to right and
but some in our audience
go right to left i believe there are
uh um
trying to think of some of the languages
that go uh left to right
but it is eluding me right now but we're
going to utilize this because it is a
awesome practice
for our python skills so now we need to
sort
our list so we need to figure out a way
to get 25
it is arabic okay i thought so but i did
not
want to embarrass myself um
we want to get 25 up here that that list
and japanese i did not know that
okay japanese is in reverse well that's
very cool
um
okay not japanese
okay well that's still very cool
okay all right so we need this list at
the top we need this list second
and we need this list third excuse me
this list third
fourth and fifth all right so does
everybody see what we need to do we need
to sort
these lists by this last item
and we're going to utilize our
function right here that we just created
and we want to say we are returning we
are saying
i want you to our key i want you to
sort this by this by the list that i'm
going to pass you
by the last item and the way that python
goes it goes
all right so cool you have you're going
to give me a list
and then you're going to you're going to
you're going to tell me the rules you're
going to i'm going to use this key and
then i'm gonna sort these
so let's jump into it
but if you're just joining us today um
thank you for doing that we're running
through the basics right now and we're
solving a very very cool puzzle if i can
find
the right notes on this all right so
let's go back to
horses so we can reassign this horses
then i'm going to pass sorted
then i'm going to pass it horses
because this is it i guess technically i
could give another variable
um okay let's do that new
new horses sorted sordid horses
key
horses horses
key then last
and you do not use parentheses because
the way
all right we have not talked about this
yet
all right so you use last
you pass it in information but when you
just
use this you're telling
python goes oh i know what that is it is
it is a function it's called last
and it lives here in memory that is
actually the memory address right there
and we'll we'll delve into that stuff
later but this is that's memory
so when you're using this you're not
passing in information you're telling
python
what to use there's one thing else we're
leaving out
and but uh so prince
for race yeah i want to
we're going to copy this i know i told
you i don't like copying
but we're not changing anything so we're
going to print it unsorted then we're
going to print it
sorted and we're going to change one
thing
let's do a print
so we can see the split
all right so
oop let's see what i did wrong what did
i leave out
sorted aha
uh sorted i think i forgot something
that's super important
anybody got any guesses so what i did
uh okay
last is this reverse
true all right
oh my word
well this is very frustrating and very
anti-climactic
because i am missing
what i am missing
so i'm going to have to only 10 minutes
left i don't think
will make it yeah uh that's probably
ah shoot because i i guess i have not
looked at this
in a while but um so the way that lambda
would work is it would go in here and i
would not have a function
oh i hate this and i don't want to start
anything new
oh bo i'm very sorry uh
i i am at a loss right now because
oh well that's embarrassing
here we go okay so what did
this is why knowing your variables is so
very important
so we we are we are good so
let's get rid of this i rushed to that
because for some reason i thought that
was it
so what happened here was because
i mean you really want to put the first
place race down here at the bottom
no so sorted has
a key and a reverse
false so we turn this on because reverse
it goes in
ascending and we're going by the last
place so first second
third but then we flipped it we turn
reverse on
true so that was why so now it is going
descending higher number because
our fastest horse 25
is right here so the fastest horse
will always be here but
as you can see we got we lucked up i
think in my example
yes so we had
we had uh i think i've had several
where we could have i don't think i've
ever run this sequence and that's what's
so cool you could run this
and run this a ton of times because one
of the actual very cool exercises that i
love
showing is the monty hall experiment
of the game the game show monty hall
and you have three doors
and you have one of them removed
and you then have to guess excuse me you
didn't have the choice of you're going
to keep your door
or change and it's a very interesting
math problem
but the reason why this works is the
randomness
you have this one this one and
this one and always your fastest horse
will end up here
but you could get them all the way out
to here
23 24 and 25 and then have these
different sorted
so maybe starting off at the end
of well actually we could then
slice this so how could we do this we
got we got four minutes
let's do it we got we still got we still
got quite a few people here we got four
minutes
let's get after it so my new
what we call it new horses
new horses
uh boom so then i need
i need uh
i need these three these two
and this one so how in the world can we
do this
so i need new
horses
so what would that be zero one two
two to the end
oops horses
ooh what i do so it's new
horses the first one
zero then two
to the end helps if
you get your variables right aha
so my last three there we go
then i need then the last two of the
second one
all right you got me so the last two of
the second one so index one
list two the last two so that's three
going forward so 20 and 24 and then i
need
the last item the last
item of our third list
so the last item of our third list it's
the third list index two
and then the last item just negative
one boom
and okay so beginning next week we will
pick up
here but you we we we can
we can add these together and put these
together and it's very very simple but
we've done
a tremendous amount of all this heavy
lifting
so i just want to say thank you guys so
much
for for participating and uh watching
our second
stream and for those of you if you're
just joining us i'm sam with python
basics
and we are doing two hour streams on
tuesday
uh for the foreseeable future and
uh all of the videos that we are doing
uh have been covered well thank you so
much
um well i really appreciate that
um we are covering things that i've
already gone over so if you
uh want to get ahead and kind of be
familiar with what we're going to talk
about but we're going to keep going with
lists
i try to i try to also uh tie these in
to puzzles and exercises because you
really begin to get to see
uh i show a lot and we work on a lot of
a lot of
different things so there we go had a
really great stream today
uh hope you guys enjoyed it i always get
a lot out of it
so as always guys thanks for watching
and we'll pick up next week bye guys